what's going on guys this is rob and the
trailer for miss marvel has dropped now
in 2015 we did a video called uh marvel
comics kamala khan miss marvel explained
but because her character had only been
out for about a year that video was more
of an origin so i basically just
retitled it to marvel comics kamala
khan's origin explained right that's
really it we'll put hashtags and
everything in there but it was basically
a 20 minute video covering her origin so
if you guys only care about her origin
that's the video that you can check out
we'll cover her origin too just not
necessarily in the same amount of depth
but regardless the character of kamala
khan was created by g willow wilson and
first appeared in miss marvel volume 3
issue number one back in 2014 now
undoubtedly those of you all who are
sort of going through and aren't really
familiar with comics or learning about
all this kind of stuff you might find
yourself where you're a little confused
because carol danvers was miss marvel
now she's captain marvel how does kamala
khan fit into all this which just fyi
over the course of this video i may end
up calling kamala khan kamala harris a
couple times right just fair warning
ahead of time right it may happen the
reality was that uh carol danvers as
miss marvel she was okay but she hadn't
really been relevant for something like
40 years i mean she was one of those
characters where because she was drawn
in a really really sexual way like boys
loved her right like guy fans loved her
but there really wasn't anything about
her character that drew interest from
female readers and so what you ended up
getting was probably one of the absolute
best carol danvers stories ever written
by kelly sudaconic which was called
captain marvel higher further faster
right it's like captain marvel vol 1.
what it did is it basically took carol
danvers away from simply being quote
unquote miss marvel and she adopted the
name of captain marvel which had
belonged to a few characters over the
years but the most notable was marvel of
the cree which worked because it was due
to like the psych magnetron and the fact
that carol danvers powers were basically
a copy of the original marvell's powers
that she ended up becoming who she was
and so the reality is following that
point uh carol danvers just simply
became known as captain marvel what this
did is it left a vacancy if marvel chose
to use it for the name of miss marvel
and so g willow wilson basically took
that mantle and gave it to a girl named
kamala kant now the way this played out
in her original appearance because it
wasn't really until volume four um that
we ended up getting like any measurable
origin beyond what we saw here initially
um in the original origin for a
character the way it played out is that
she was a byproduct of the terrigen bomb
now those of you guys who don't who
aren't really familiar with that during
uh god during jonathan hickman's
avengers the new avengers best comic
book story ever told there was a story
that was called infinity where basically
thanos invaded the earth looking for a
son he ended up getting into a conflict
with the inhumans and in probably one of
the best comic book fights ever he ended
up fighting black bolt of the inhumans
who was basically the inhuman king
during this conflict black bolt
detonated the terrigen bomb which
basically spread the terrigen myths
across the world whenever an inhuman is
exposed to the terrorism miss they
develop powers the powers are based on
whatever their previously created uh
genealogy was and that's not necessarily
important here the important thing is
that for kamala khan she gained her
powers because she was basically in the
wrong place at the wrong time uh she had
snuck out of her house ignoring the
directions of her parents which of
course we'll talk about that whole
familiar relationship here in a minute
since that's the really really important
part of her character's storytelling as
well as her friend bruno and then tried
to go to a party in order to you know
hang out with her friends and so on and
again the kind of character mannerisms
of her those were important so we'll
talk about those here in a minute but
the results of this is that on her way
back the terrigen miss had basically hit
her right she had just kind of been
engulfed by them and when that took
place much like virtually all inhumans
she had had a cocoon that was formed
around her and then from there it was
really meta-textual she had this vision
where she essentially met with like what
she what she considered to be her three
favorite superheroes so like captain
america carol danvers of course and then
iron man the reality is that carol
danvers was the one that she had always
idolized and that was really g willow
wilson establishing uh kamala khan as
essentially a stand-in for young female
readers right that uh with with carol
danvers becoming captain marvel becoming
very much the sort of step up from where
she was before she wasn't just some girl
who was walking around in like a one
piece right drawn in a very voluptuous
way but instead was a woman who had a
position of authority a position of
power which she was never afraid to
exercise that kamala khan was designed
to be the girl who just went into a
comic book store and wanted to see more
more women and comics in roles of
leadership and so the result of this is
that while she did talk to captain
america did talk to iron man it was
really the conversation with carol
danvers that was the most significant
but the truth about this is that because
it was only really a vision it was
really more her subconscious or even her
conscience that was having a
conversation with her right just kind of
basically telling her like you know it's
it's you shouldn't have ignored your
parents different things along those
lines but what g willow wilson did was
always something was also really really
really cool the nature of being a
teenager is such that your life is an
existential crisis you don't know who
you are you don't know where you're
going you don't know what you're about
you know nothing about yourself
and and even then sometimes we never get
past that existential crisis stage right
like over the course of our lives like i
didn't figure myself out until i was 30.
right i had no idea what i wanted in
this life until i was like 30 or 31.
sometimes it just takes that long to
figure it out and that was the other
part of the conversation that was being
had here was what do you want in this
life kamala khan like what's important
to you now the reason why this
conversation was so significant was
because leading up to the point where
she was exposed to the terrigen mist one
of the big things that was established
is that she was of pakistani origin and
that her family was very very
traditional insofar as familial ties
rules laid down by the parents which the
children obey different things along
those lines and so it was one of those
situations where and again we'll kind of
talk about this a little bit later she
was at a kind of fork on the road where
she wanted to make a choice about what
kind of life she wanted to live but she
wasn't entirely sure what she wanted to
do and so what she did is she simply
said like she wanted to be more like
captain marvel she wanted to be more
like carol danvers who she described as
just being beautiful and amazing and
just all these things that were really
just uh just adjectives designed to show
that she looked up to the character and
so what ended up happening is that
following the end of her vision so to
speak and the terrigen miss kind of
running their course and her gaining her
powers and emerging from the cocoon that
she was essentially able to control her
body on the molecular level now the
reason why this matters is because
whenever it comes to a person's ability
to control their body or individual
things on the atomic or the molecular
level you're only ever one step away
right one story arc one power expansion
from being able to do that on like a
planetary or even a universal level
atoms don't change molecules don't
change the things that make up molecules
change right the atoms that compose
molecules that changes over time but the
nature is that atoms themselves do not
change and so the truth is being able to
manipulate molecules is being able to
manipulate atoms and if you can
manipulate atoms you can do virtually
anything the reason why i say this is
because kamala khan can basically alter
the structure of her own body on the
molecular level and her powers of kind
of have really seen bits of expansion
here and there but we're all just kind
of waiting for that point where some
story arc takes place and then she's
able to like alter the biosphere or
something crazy like that right just
something absolutely nuts but by and
large her powers were very very similar
and still are very similar to reid
richards of the fantastic four right mr
fantastic the ability to stretch the
ability to expand her mass different
things along those lines and so
following this and really kind of
returning home what it did is it allowed
g willow wilson to set the stage for
probably one of the coolest elements of
of kamala khan right this whole idea
being that now she was a very much a
kind of spider-man-esque character you
know that as a teenager she was trying
to fit in she had her friend bruno uh
and she was trying to be cool but now
also trying to figure out how to use her
powers at the exact same time now of
course once she got home and basically
bruno would spill the beans on what are
going on and her her parents found out
that she had snuck out she was grounded
for what basically felt like forever
right when you're a teenager and you're
grounded a week is an eternity right i
mean you guys know you guys know like
you guys haven't been there before like
it sucks
but it's one of those things where it
just kind of felt like forever now
following this and really over the first
seven issues or so of of kamala khan's
stories there were a few things that was
happening and in fact it was a really
interesting change of pace from what you
normally saw right even now to this day
in a lot of ways the old stan lee jack
kirby method is still used in marvel
comics which is to say introduce a new
character and then shop them around the
marvel universe in order to get people
familiar with them right so have them
team up with a fantastic four or appear
in a fantastic four comic have them team
up with captain america or team up with
spider-man or something along those
lines right comics that are established
that you know people read so that you
can introduce this character to an
audience that either didn't know they
existed or didn't really see a reason to
read them in the first place in the
hopes that the nature of that character
as they're depicted in the comics would
resonate with the reader who had never
read their comics so that reader would
now start reading their comics
and so the result of this is that a few
things happen um the first is that
dealing with more of the personality
traits of kamala khan and dealing with
the various issues she was going through
as a teenager a young girl trying to
figure out her place in the world which
was now complicated by the addition of
powers that of course she and bruno had
a bit of a falling out because of the
fact that bruno had basically made her
parents aware of what was going on bruno
was coming from a place of concern he
didn't really want her to get hurt he
didn't want anything bad to happen to
her but at the end of the day it felt
like a betrayal so there was that sort
of uh character theme which of course
led to the two of them reconciling
because they're friends right you can't
stay mad at your friend forever um and
then in turn it was also her trying to
become a superhero now the reality of
this and this is one of those things
that again made it pretty cool is that
there wasn't really anybody to guide her
right it was very similar to spider-man
right back when peter parker first
became spider-man in the 60s he didn't
really have a tutor there really wasn't
anybody who took him under their wing
and said we're going to teach you how to
be a superhero spider-man instead he was
flying by the seat of her pants and
while kamala khan was not like the first
person to go through that entire concept
after spider-man a lot of people had it
was really cool to see that that concept
was still alive and well in marvel
comics and so she was basically trying
to figure herself out and she had a few
small little things here and there right
fighting against some villain called the
inventor and then learning that she had
a secondary power that whenever she was
in her quote unquote superhero form that
if she was injured which as she was she
had basically been attacked that she
could revert back to her normal form and
it would heal they're kind of a healing
factor to a degree not in the
traditional sense like wolverine but
nonetheless it was really more akin to
like uh like iceman like if bobby drake
is injured in his ice form uh he can
revert to his human form and basically
be fine or if he's in his human form and
he's injured he can turn into his ice
form back into his human form and
everything's basically copacetic right
that kind of a that kind of a situation
but what you also saw was her trying to
track down somebody called the inventor
who was just really really small time
not enough for the avengers or anybody
to care about but the perfect kind of
villain for someone like kamala khan
who's basically brand new to the
superhero scene it was a weird thing
where like this guy gregory knox had
tried to clone his bird and then he
ended up getting like this giant hybrid
bird right it was just it was it was
weird it was this great big huge weird
thing ended up in a you know ended up
leading to a fight in the sewers and
that kind of stuff but she was
ultimately saved by wolverine and then
fighting alongside wolverine they
actually ended up defeating like these
just monstrous alligators and so on
again not a great big huge set of events
which is good it's not as though she
first appeared and then she was
immediately out in space fighting thanos
alongside the avengers in the fantastic
four it wasn't really anything like that
instead g willow wilson's take was
gradually introduce people to the
character the more important thing that
she was doing was introducing people to
the personality of kamala khan and
getting people to care about her
personality now the reason why that was
done for those of you all who are
unfamiliar with comics is that it's not
hard to craft an event where like things
are popping off and people are fighting
that's super easy to do what's hard to
do in comics is create a character with
a personality that's written in such a
way to where you're interested in them
the other part of this is that g willow
wilson had realized there wasn't really
a lot of pakistani representation in
marvel comics or even in comics in
general unless you were reading
something written by independent writers
and so adding that element and like the
familial aspects and things like that
giving people a general perception of
what pakistani life is like for a
pakistani girl living in america was one
thing that really resonated with a lot
of young readers and in fact it was
really a core part of her character
because what you saw in the early days
with kamala khan was basically her
struggling with like the independence
and the freedom and the non-traditional
elements of american life because one of
the things you saw was kamala khan
dealing with these struggles of the
traditional nature of her pakistani
family conflicting with more differing
ideologies of the american system right
the american societal system and so
there was a lot of bumping heads there
right she wanted to live the life that a
lot of young americans do which in a lot
of ways conflicted with the life that
her parents were trying to get her to
live and so it was one of those really
interesting concepts because it really
really again resonated with a lot of
people now again one of the things we've
talked about in previous videos where
we've covered characters who appeared
between 2014 and 2015 is that marvel was
wrapping things up right remember there
was a whole event of secret wars in 2015
the collapse of the multiverse the end
of all things so within a year of kamala
khan appearing in marvel comics the idea
that like medusa and black bolt of the
inhumans were basically issuing an
invitation not so much forcing but
issuing an invitation for those various
people out there who had been
transformed and learned that they were
in humans to join the inhuman society in
attilan uh that while there was this
idea of wolverine contacting medusa in
order to keep an eye on on kamala khan
again that happened in issue number
seven that the reality is that g willow
wilson was focusing more on the
character than great big huge events
because that's all she really could do
right that like things were coming to an
end right things were wrapping up the
multiverse was ending and we knew that
we were going to end up going into
either a reboot or a reshuffling of
everything and so what we ended up
getting is that in secret wars 2015 the
multiverse was destroyed right it was
completely eradicated due to the results
of the white lords of wild space right
the beyonders and like the molecule man
owen reese and the illuminati and all
that kind of stuff it all ended up going
belly up and so what we got following
that was the return of the multiverse
that was all basically restored by reed
richards his son franklin richards who
can alter reality on a universal level
kind of a universal shaper as he was
described and the molecule man owen
reese and so what this did is it saw the
launch of something called all new all
different marvel which i'm sure a lot of
you all saw and it wasn't really all new
or all different it was just a name that
marvel used in order to get people to
buy the comics so the thing about this
is that uh following that while g willow
wilson did return and you did get miss
marvel vol 4 because of the fact that
the origin era had basically passed a
majority of her appearances were really
confined to the avengers and while i
wouldn't say she had become irrelevant
um while you did have her solo series in
terms of the avengers she was just there
right and she just did some stuff and
some things happened and then the story
was over and that was basically it there
wasn't really a whole lot going on
however one of the big things that was
taking place during that time is marvel
was setting the stage for the idea of
the champions and the reason for this is
that within the first three issues of
all new all different avengers you
actually ended up seeing a kind of team
up between kamala khan and sam alexander
who was the newest iteration of nova and
one of the most fun characters ever in
the history of marvel comics i love sam
alexander he's so amazing i can't wait
till we get him in the mcu it's only a
matter of time he's like this teenage
like he's like this teenage kid who has
the power to like go into space and
fight threats right he's part of the
nova corps right so it's really well at
least his dad was and then like his old
his whole origin story was like the hunt
for his dad and all that kind of cool
stuff but the thing about this is that
the two of them ended up teaming up and
in fact sam alexander had actually tried
to flirt with kamala khan and tried to
like hit on her a few times and between
her being just sort of socially awkward
and the fact that they're like we're
kind of fighting a threat now's not
really the time for flirting she
ultimately rebuffed it now following
that you actually saw the uh the all-new
all different avengers or at least these
younger characters teaming up yet again
when you saw miles morales being brought
in and miles and nova and kamala khan
facing off against yet another threat
now again this is one of those instances
where people sort of look at all new all
different marvel as in a lot of ways
just an era of debacle storytelling
because following that you basically had
a series of events that were written by
marvel that were designed to do nothing
than be cash grabs for like the marvel
cinematic universe so where the original
civil war by uh mark miller is kind of
considered to be a masterpiece just
based on on like the the sheer depth and
everything that was happening with
regards to superhero community civil war
ii was the opposite of that that it was
basically a cash grab that sucked and so
for the most part you ended up seeing
like a few things like nothing really
significant happened except that like
tony stark died everybody saw carol
danvers as a dick well depending on who
you're talking to people saw it as
character assassination for carol
danvers and then uh miles morales quote
unquote killing captain america it was
that kind of a thing right there were a
few things that were going on here and
there but it was really more shock value
as opposed to it having any real value
in any form or fashion and so with the
second civil war event basically
wrapping up coming to a close what it
did is it led to in a lot of ways uh
kamala khan and miles morales and sam
alexander and a lot of these guys really
just kind of being disenchanted with the
nature of the avengers and so they
ultimately defected and what they ended
up doing is with nova and spider-man
quitting you ended up having kamala khan
who did the same thing and a lot of this
was because looking around at the events
of civil war looking at the collateral
damage looking at all the things that
had gone on that these three had
basically come to the conclusion that in
essence the avengers didn't care about
the small people they didn't care about
the little things right the person
walking down the road or the collateral
damage that was done it was one of those
where in years past well damage control
takes care of all that right that's
basically it damage control will make
them whole we're really sorry you're on
and uncle died uh but hey you know it's
just is your sport of living in new york
i don't know what to tell you right that
was just the general gist of the
avengers for the most part and so
ultimately the champions were formed as
an answer to the question what group out
there is going to help take care of the
small people and the champions were
amazing the champions were always
awesome in fact i loved the concept of
the champions in marvel comics now
something that i do want to point out
here is that the champions were not just
these three right it was not just nova
and miles and and kamala khan instead
what you also ended up getting added
onto the team was amadeus cho who was
the eighth smartest person in the world
who'd become the newest iteration of the
incredible hulk following basically the
death of bruce banner uh you got the
vision's daughter vivian who was cool
but always a little bit sketchy and then
you had the time display cyclops now the
time display cyclops was really a bigger
part with regards to the time displaced
x-men the idea that like everything
going on with cyclops at the time and
everything going on with the x-men at
the time was such that beast had felt
like the team had lost their way so he
had traveled into the past to grab the
younger versions of themselves brought
them to the modern era in order to try
to bring the x-men back to who they were
supposed to be and then the team just
never left and uh honestly they stopped
being cool after about three story arcs
so people were just kind of like okay i
mean whatever but like putting the
younger cyclops the time display cyclops
on that team was a great way to kind of
keep him relevant to a degree until we
were waiting for the original cyclops to
come back from the dead after his
supposed death now depending on who
you're talking to some people will say
the biggest issue with the champions is
that they were basically like a social
justice warrior team right that there
was a point in marvel comics following
all new all different marvel and even
part of all new all different marvel
were in a lot of ways there was a lot of
political storytelling you guys may
remember that it was a very divisive
time among the fan base in marvel um i
always enjoyed that era of the champions
i will say that jim zub's run and
champions vol 3 was particularly
interesting because what you saw was
that while the team originally consisted
of only a handful of people what you
ended up getting was the team basically
going worldwide though you actually
ended up seeing like falcon and patriot
and like the new power man and these
characters basically given membership
and then in turn it was like a champions
team around the world right so in a lot
of ways it was similar to like batman
incorporated for those of you guys who
are familiar with grant morrison's
batman run but basically like like that
whole thing right it was very similar to
that and it was great for what it was it
was absolutely phenomenal we can cover
champions at some point or even do like
a champions explained right because that
that requires a whole great big huge
thing but the reality is that kamala
khan was way more interesting when she
was on the champions than she ever was
in terms of her solo series because by
this point in time g willow wilson had
long since left writing and so it was
one of those things where it was kind of
like people weren't able to really
capture the character in a way that g
willow wilson was because g willow
wilson was a pakistani woman writing
about a pakistani character and unless
you're able to specifically identify
with the character that you're writing
you will ultimately end up being you
know kind of losing the element of that
character right losing the core thing
that makes them exceedingly relatable
and so because of this in 2020 or at
least january of 2020 uh miss marvel's
comic which had already been retitled to
the magnificent miss marvel was axed by
marvel they ended up cancelling it and
instead what they did is they shifted
the focus of kamala khan over to the
champions so the champions comic itself
was in a lot of ways one part focusing
on the team but then also giving a
little more emphasis to the character of
kamala khan than anybody else and that's
the reason why once the events of the
secret empire storyline kicked off there
was a lot of emphasis put on the
individual events going on with kamala
khan as opposed to seemingly anything
else that what ended up happening here
is that for those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with secret empire this
basically led to the red skull capturing
a cosmic cue i mean it was really
predicated on like avengers standoff and
like pleasant hill and all that kind of
stuff but basically a cosmic cube had
been taken by the red skull and really
it reformed in uh in cubic i can never
remember her name there's the original
which i think is comic and then there's
the modern one which i think is cubic
but basically it was a little girl who
was young and naive we had a cosmic cube
that was that really kind of follow the
form and function of just a young
inexperienced girl and the red skull had
manipulated her into altering the
reality of captain america and really
altering the universe itself and so what
this basically meant is captain
america's entire history was rewritten
so that steve rogers never became
captain america or at least he did but
the entire time he was basically a
secret operative for hydra nobody really
knew right he had just been a hydra
agent who had been sinned or who had
lived in the united states and had
become captain america all the while
working to ensure that hydra would come
to power now eventually he took out the
red skull succeeded the red skull took
over hydra itself and then launched
secret empire and that was basically him
conquering the united states and then
actually having his sights set on the
world which he successfully conquered
the states but for the story of kamala
khan herself within champions what you
ended up learning is that because
anybody out there who was like an
inhuman or something like that had
basically been rounded up and put in
internment camps it was really her and
even a few a few other members of the
champions operating as basically freedom
fighters right they were they're almost
kind of like a modern day freedom force
right for those of you guys who remember
not really government sanctioned but in
terms of the form and function but
essentially traveling around and like
rescuing members of the inhuman
community who had been you know put in
concentration camps right liberating
them in a lot of ways and so it was
really really cool to see that element
maintained and of course the aspect of
bruno and her familiar relations and
different things along those lines those
still remained intact but for the most
part champions focused more on the
superhero element of kamala khan than it
did on the familial ties and things like
that a lot of the interpersonal
struggles outside of the team and really
just regarding her family kind of fell
to the background and so what you have
going on right now in marvel comics
regarding the champions is the underage
superhero registration act and basically
cradle now cradle is the child hero
reconnaissance and disruption law
enforcement division right organization
essentially but the way this went down
is that the reality as far as the world
was concerned is that having teenagers
fight as superheroes which is too big of
a risk right like teenagers are
naturally reckless when you add in
superpowers and seemingly no thought to
the consequences it can lead to a
terrible situation and this played out
in the events of outlawed now the way
the outlawed storyline played out was
that you basically ended up having like
roxanne who's it's like they're like if
amazon and facebook were the same
company right just like really really
shady and doing terrible things um did
they kind of unleash an asgardian dragon
and when that happened uh you ended up
seeing kamala khan basically bring back
or at least assemble the champions who
had not necessarily been cancelled or
been removed but just kind of been out
there doing their own thing as
individuals unofficially operating as a
team um and when that happened vision's
daughter exploded which actually was
very similar to the events of nitro in
the original uh civil war storyline
during that time you had senator joffrey
patrick who's really more of like a
modern-day robert kelly uh that
basically ended up passing kamala's law
basically a law that said any person
under the age of 21 cannot operate as a
superhero unless they're being monitored
by an experienced adult and so when
kamala khan woke up she was pissed
because somebody had passed a law like
that in her name basically banning her
she had spoken publicly on quote unquote
behalf of the champions which created
even more issues because the champions
didn't want someone speaking for her
because not all of them disagreed with
the passage of the law and so ultimately
what ended up happening or at least
we're seeing stan at the moment is that
in the middle of one of their meetings
cradle had basically invaded snatched a
whole bunch of them up and kamala khan
was able to make her escape we don't
really know exactly how this is going to
play out but it is pretty cool right
outlawed is a pretty cool storyline but
that's kind of the the explanation of of
kamala khan again there is a lot of
stuff that we left out because we simply
just don't have time we'll probably
start covering like more miss marvel
stuff as we get closer to the release of
the tv show in june uh but if you guys
enjoyed this video drop a like thank you
all for watching and i will catch you
all later
peace